to set this up there's a dynamic that
we've talked about before uh where
people would ask us the the secret to
our friendship longevity of our
friendship and I would all often say
having um a common goal having something
that you're working on together is a
great way to kind of keep you friends in
other words it's like a married couple
staying married for the sake of the kids
but what happens when couples that are
together for the kids become empty
nesters a lot of times they end up
getting divorced right or they have like
a reinvention of their relationship so
link once pointed out to me that it was
hurtful that he used that I use that
Dynamic and I think may maybe in that
email or maybe in the subsequent
conversation about it when you were like
I get what you're saying and I don't
think it's untrue but really it kind of
makes it sound like the only reason
we're friends is because we're working
on something together and I was like you
know what you're right I'm going to stop
using that analogy or I'm going to stop
using it in isolation I'm going to have
other things that I say I'm going to be
like well I actually love this guy and I
want to be his friend that's why we're
friends and then here are some maybe
some keys to like staying good friends
but there's a dynamic that you often use
in describing our wife's relation our
wives relationship and that is it's kind
of an arranged marriage now I'll take
two two issues with that number one
every relationship is arranged is
circumstantial our our friendship is
based on the fact that we went to the
same school my parents moved to buoy
Creek and you were in class or whatever
can I just I'm getting uncomfortable do
you want to see in this room or is it
something you two want to work out uh I
like glancing over and looking at your
encouraging I feel like I need you go
ahead keep but but the wonderful thing
is I think that besides me my w wife's
favorite person is your
wife it is an arranged marriage right
but what I'm saying when you lead with
that what it sounds like is you know
well they probably wouldn't be friends
if it wasn't for us and what I'm saying
that's true what and so and I don't
agree with that because well they
wouldn't have ever met yeah but I'm
saying but I feel like that puts the
emphasis in the wrong place because I
think our our wives are I think it's a
mischaracterization of our wives
relationship because they're actually
really really close talk all the time oh
yeah consider each other best friends
some of the best marriages are arranged
marriages am I right so here's the thing
because I changed I am so confused
because the way I change the way that I
talk about our friendship I what I'm
asking you to do is when people ask us
about our wives you always lead with
well it's kind of an arranged marriage I
think you should say our wives are best
friends because they are and it's true
it's a setup and I think that that's how
you should characterize it you know
they're our wives are best friends see
just start with that we arranged the
best friendship we get credit for it has
your wife said that she is upset with
the way that he talks about their
friendship no is that where this is
coming from or is this this is coming
from me from you yeah yeah she doesn't
listen to anything I love what I'm
getting your Dynamic is U if there
aren't problems we create them you can
create them and then try to fix yeah
[__] that doesn't exist that's what
relationships are all
[Music]
about